This week on Ask a Teacher, we answer a question from Rohullah in Afghanistan about using the words "sew" and "knit" and related terms.
本周在《问老师》节目中，我们回答来自阿富汗的Rohullah提出的关于使用“缝”和“织”及相关词汇的问题。
Dear VOA Learning English,
亲爱的VOA学英语：
I am sending this email to know what the differences are between "sewing and knitting" or "sew and knit."
我发这封邮件是想知道“缝纫和编织”或“缝和织”之间的区别。
Besides [that], I wanted to know what I can call a woman or a man that makes clothes.
除此之外，我还想知道可以怎么称呼做衣服的男人或女人。
Thank you
谢谢。
I'm happy to answer this question, Rohullah.
Rohullah，我很高兴回答这个问题。
An important difference between sewing and knitting is that when we sew, we connect pieces of fabric or cloth that are already made.
缝纫和编织的一个重要区别是，当我们缝纫时，我们连接已经做好的布料或织物片。
When we knit, we make the cloth itself from strings called yarn.
当我们编织时，我们用叫做纱线的线来制作布料本身。
Also, the word "sewing" can describe many ways people connect or repair fabric and clothes.
此外，“缝纫”这个词可以描述人们连接或修补布料和衣服的多种方式。
For example, people can sew many kinds of clothes, such as socks, shirts, dresses, hats, and gloves.
例如，人们可以缝制多种衣服，如袜子、衬衫、连衣裙、帽子和手套。
People can also sew larger things, such as window coverings or tents.
人们还可以缝制更大的物品，如窗帘或帐篷。
A person can sew using a sewing machine or simply by using their hands with a needle and thread.
一个人可以用缝纫机缝纫，也可以只用针线手工缝纫。
Knitting does not generally require use of a machine or a needle and thread.
编织通常不需要使用机器或针线。
To knit, a person uses thicker strings called yarn, along with two thin sticks called knitting needles.
编织时，人们使用较粗的线（称为纱线），以及两根细棒（称为织针）。
Yarn is usually made of small, natural pieces, called fibers, such as wool or cotton.
纱线通常由细小的天然纤维制成，如羊毛或棉花。
While sewing thread is often less than one millimeter thick, knitting yarn is generally two to five millimeters thick.
缝纫线通常不到一毫米粗，而编织纱线通常有两到五毫米粗。
Many people who knit make clothing for cold weather, such as wool sweaters, hats, and scarves.
许多编织者制作寒冷天气穿的衣服，如羊毛衫、帽子和围巾。
They may also knit blankets or other things that can be used in the home.
他们也可能编织毯子或其他家中可用的物品。
More than 50 years ago, most Americans who earned money sewing clothes in a factory were women. They were called "seamstresses."
五十多年前，大多数在工厂靠缝制衣服赚钱的美国人都是女性。她们被称为“女裁缝”。
Today, we sometimes call any person who sews a "sewist."
今天，我们有时称任何缝纫的人为“缝纫者”。
Or we can simply say "a person who sews."
或者我们可以简单地说“一个缝纫的人”。
And a person whose job is to sew or repair clothes to make them fit well is called a tailor.
而一个以缝制或修补衣服使其合身为职业的人被称为裁缝。
For our readers and listeners, what are your questions about American English?
对于我们的读者和听众，你们对美国英语有什么问题吗？
Do you like to knit or sew?
你喜欢编织还是缝纫？
We want to hear from you! Send us an email at learningenglish@voanews.com.
我们想听到你的声音！请给我们发邮件至learningenglish@voanews.com。
And please let us know where you are from, too.
也请告诉我们你来自哪里。
And that's Ask a Teacher.
这就是《问老师》节目。
I'm Andrew Smith.
我是安德鲁·史密斯。